what is it like to be  a hundred  these believe it or not are the very  best years of my life  how are you able to  not just run marathons and half  marathons in your late 80s and over the  course of your 90s but also set world  records like what is the  secret to longevity here no question in  my mind absolutely it is diet that is to  determine  my existence my continued existence  and my beautiful health essentially for  the last 30 years you've been eating a  very strict whole 100  yeah so it's it's around 60 where you  start getting competitive though  as i understand is that correct  not really  i don't think i ever became competitive  actually until  i was 88  for my age i'm  practically number one yeah